>>Jon Bergmann: Here are
some tips to overcome some
of the hurdles and blunders
that we've seen commonly happen
as teachers flip
their classrooms.
>>Aaron Sams: Make sure your
students can access the content.
We all know that not
all students have access
to the Internet at their
home, so you may have to come
up with some other solutions.
Get some flash drives,
check them out to students;
burn the video content onto
DVDs; or write a grant,
get a class set of some
sort of digital device
that you can check
out to your students
and they can take
home and use that way.
>>Jon Bergmann: Make sure
you teach your students how
to watch a video.
You say, "My kids know
how to watch a video."
Yes, they know how
to watch "Spiderman",
but that's not the same as
watching an educational video
that you've created
for them to watch.
Ultimately you're trying to
teach them how to interact
with the video content in a
meaningful way that causes them
to reflect and think through
what they're being exposed to.
I had a conversation with a
sixth grade teacher and he said,
"I spent three weeks teaching my
students how to watch a video."
He had, you know, little guys,
you know, twelve-year olds.
I had sixteen-year olds.
It makes a huge difference based
on the maturity of the kids
and what they are ready
and prepared to learn.
>>Aaron Sams: Keep in
mind that the length
of the video does matter.
Our rule of thumb is one to one
and a half minutes per grade
level that the students are in.
So a fourth grade student--
you're talking four
to six minutes max.
A tenth grade student--
ten to fifteen maximum.
Keep it short and if you need to
make more videos that are short,
that's better than making
fewer videos that are long.
Another question that a lot of
teachers ask is, "What do I do
if students show up to my class
and they haven't
viewed the content?"
Well, let's be real here.
I mean, there are kids who are
gonna show up to any classroom
who haven't done their homework.
That's just a reality that
we live in as educators.
It's really not that different
in a flipped classroom.
But there are ways that you can
safeguard or build in some steps
to keep kids engaged while
they're viewing the content
and that you can use to
check to see if they have.
We took the low-tech approach;
we just wanted to
see some notes.
Other teachers are embedding
these videos onto a webpage
and embedding like a
Google form underneath it
to collect some data
from the students,
having them answer
some questions.
You could just pose a question
in the video themselves
and have the students bring
the answer to that question
as an entrance ticket
into class.
So there's all sorts
of different ways
that you can check to see if
students actually did their work
and then you as a
teacher, as an educator,
will just hold them
accountable for that.
>>Jon Bergmann: Ultimately,
I think the key is
that you hold kids accountable.
If they've made the poor
choice of not doing the work,
then what you're gonna do is
you're gonna take that time
and you're gonna say, "You
know have to watch the video
in class while the other
kids are getting help
on the hard stuff."
>>Aaron Sams: So some teachers
get a little intimidated
by this idea of creating
their own videos.
Really you don't need
a super-duper studio.
You don't need to worry
about high-dollar cameras
and things like that.
But there are a few
techniques that you can do
to really improve the
quality of you stuff.
So sit in a room with good
lights, have a nice area to work
and don't have a
distracting background.
Have it something
nice and simple.
Those are things that you can
introduce to help the quality.
Another question you
should ask yourself is,
"Do I need it to be perfect?
Or do I need it on Tuesday?"
So some teachers can get
bogged down in trying
to have everything just
perfect, but how many
of your actual live lessons in
a classroom have been perfect?
Probably not very many.
We teach naturally.
We teach organically and
we speak to our students
in a way that's meaningful
to them.
Make these videos the same way;
just make them effective
content-delivery tools.
Don't worry about trying to
make a Hollywood production
out of it.
>>Jon Bergmann: One
of the beauties
of the flipped class
is it's very scalable.
You know what?
You don't have to flip a class.
You could flip one lesson.
Or you could flip a unit.
Or you could flip a whole class.
It's scalable.
So one recommendation we would
have for you is maybe you need
to start small and figure out
what's the best place to flip.
If I were to give
you a recommendation
of what you should flip if
you're looking for a lesson,
find something that
your kids struggle with.
I was working with a group
of fourth grade teachers
and we were talking about math.
And they said-- in
unison they said,
"My kids struggle
with long division."
I said, "That's your first
flipped class video is
long division."
So what's the equivalent
of long division for you?
That's your first
lesson to flip.
>>Aaron Sams: So to
recap, make sure all
of your students have
access to the content.
>>Jon Bergmann: Make sure
to teach them how
to watch the videos.
>>Aaron Sams: Build in some
safeguards to make sure
that all students are
actually watching the videos.
>>Jon Bergmann: Don't
feel the need
to make your videos perfect.
>>Aaron Sams: And don't try
to do too much all at once.
Take it step-by-step,
take it slow
and before long you'll
have flipped your class.
>>[applause]